stop wheezing why I love being black oh
my god there is so much richness and
history behind my skin I just love the
soul like I don't know how to describe
it other than that do you see the skin
we're not just one part of the Box
toughest everything because what I think
about black culture I think about how
powerful it is I think about the fact
that our ancestors are the ones that you
could not break if I walk up and out
with anything other than black I would
be completely jealous that's what is
linked you know my melanin pop that's a
lot of outfit works you don't see nobody
else rocking a baby blue outfit out here
like this
with life like love but whenever we come
together I'm saying this is like no one
nothing else before I came to America
black was the only thing I knew nobody
can take this away from me black just
doesn't have one definition my black is
different from her black I can come to a
place like this and just see so much
beauty and diversity see so many people
who are just like proud of their melanin
and like dances to our own music the
originality in the strength never
duplicated always imitated but this is
strengthen the creativity that we have
in our culture
we're loud and we're proud of it and the
culture is so fricking rich it's like
wherever you go in the world is a kind
of unity like everyone knows the not all
of our features like there's nothing
like it
the Sun can't even break us we just
created this whole culture that's like
it's influencing the entire world now as
it says on my I am dipped in chocolate
inelegant enables with grace and I am
toasted with beauty that is why I love
being black I think that it's amazing to
come from a people who have overcome one
who have strived to be great people who
are great
we always are given scraps like chitlins
the bottoms of the bottom and we take
those things and like make them into
like cultural staple or selectively wear
one but individually we're beautiful
people you can't pinpoint back where
exactly you came from but you can feel
we're not confined to one thing I
learned from different people different
cultures that were all brought together
by the cultivars in black women can wear
any color of the rainbow and look
amazing a month like the discrimination
and the racial tension in our country I
still wouldn't rather be anything else
we are like a community of beauty and
resiliency honestly like it's so funny
it's so many things come on now look at
our fashion of our rules look where we
come from why wouldn't you want to be
black